hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 american science fiction disaster
movie called moonfall
the movie begins on january 12 2011 when
a crew of astronauts goes on a mission
to repair a satellite in outer space
everything goes well until astronaut
brian harper notices a swarm of nanotech
creatures flying towards them
the swarm attacks the satellite in the
spaceship causing marcus to get thrown
away
harper tries to help him but
unfortunately gets pulled back to the
spaceship
he manages to get into the shuttle and
attempts to contact marcus but to no
avail
the commander jose de fowler is
unconscious due to the crash and he
decides to fly the survivors back to
earth
18 months after the accident harper
testifies to the court about what was
happening back then while commander joe
also presents as a witness but everyone
eventually concludes that the accident
was the result of human error
since then harper has become disgraced
by nasa and is divorced by his wife who
decides to move to new jersey after they
lost their house
ten years later a megastructurist named
kc houseman sneaks into the university
of california logging into their
telescope to gather information about
the moon turns out that he is just a
regular man who works at a fast food
restaurant where he receives an email
that confirms his wild hypothesis about
the moon's unusual activity he attempts
to contact nasa several times but his
calls are ignored
he later finds a newspaper and gets an
idea to meet harper on astronaut day's
celebration
while waiting for him at the museum he
tells the children a story about the
moon stating that the moon is actually a
megastructure
not long after harper shows up and
houseman tries to present his research
and information about the moon getting
closer to earth but he thinks that
houseman is crazy and dismisses him
the security even have to take him out
of the museum
just as he is taken away he throws all
the papers towards brian hoping that he
will read it later afterwards houseman
pays a visit to his mother who suffers
from alzheimer's disease
she doesn't even recognize her own son
on the other hand commander joe is still
working at nasa and is informed that the
moon's orbit has shifted they also
notice a strange activity on the moon
but at this point they still have no
idea what that is
meanwhile harper now lives alone while
his ex-wife brenda has married another
guy named tom and has two daughters with
him
she calls harper to inform him that
their son sonny is being arrested by the
police on the news
the next day he goes to his bail hearing
since harper keeps interrupting during
the hearing the judge has to postpone
the hearing for a week meaning that
sonny has to stay in jail for that
amount of time
to make things worse harper even tries
to bribe the judge to let sunny out
joe and her team finally discover that
the moon is heading towards earth and
its city-sized debris will hit the earth
in three weeks they also find a hole on
the moon's surface meaning that their
time is getting shorter and shorter
shortly after the news about the moon
leaks to the public and becomes trending
in social media
general doug davidson who turns out to
be joe's ex-husband immediately calls
joe to confirm the information while
asking their son's condition jimmy
nasa conducts a press conference to
clarify everything telling the others to
calm down and nothing to worry about
however everyone panics chaos happening
everywhere and frantic shoppers continue
to stockpile supplies at the same time
nasa organizes a shuttle launch with a
crew of three astronauts to investigate
their findings on the moon's surface
unfortunately just as they release a
probe to the moon's hole the same swarm
appears and attacks the shuttle
it breaks into the shuttle and kills the
entire crew
on the other hand everyone starts to
evacuate and the news also begins to
mention that the moon is actually some
sort of orbital megastructure which
shocks harper he finds footage of
houseman talking about the moon's
anomaly thus he later decides to
approach him
houseman reveals that he has been
studying distant planets for years
searching for megastructures that are
orbiting in our solar system
soon after a tsunami hits california
wherein harper has to help housman when
he gets swept up by the water
luckily they are still able to survive
back to joe her colleague gives up as he
realizes that they have been defeated by
nature but she still wants to fight
she digs into nasa's old archives and
finds cam footage from harper's suits
during their failed mission
suddenly she is confronted by
holdenfield an archivist who knows that
nasa was covering something during the
1969 apollo moon landing
she later conducts a conference meeting
with the military who plans to launch
nukes on the moon
she is confident that there's a
possibility to knock the moon back to
its original orbit without destroying it
a few moments later joe calls doug to
discuss about an emp called zulu x-ray 7
in which she believes that it solves
everything in the evening houseman and
harper are picked up and brought to the
nasa's facility
joe comes into the room while harper
clarifies that he doesn't want to take
orders from her anymore but he cannot do
much now
joe plans to attack the swarm as she
believes that killing it might stop the
moon from getting closer to the earth
she asks for harper's help because the
swarm recognizes humans technology and
he's the only pilot who is capable of
landing a shuttle without power
after everyone agrees to the mission
they get a shuttle out of a museum
hoping that it's still functioning
houseman and joe later meet colonel reed
and captain avery who will assist them
on the mission
the emp has also been prepared and is
ready to be used without permission from
the earth
before they depart joe releases sonny
from the prison and brings him to air
force base where he finally meets his
father again
as a huge earthquake occurs and another
disaster is imminent joe and harper act
quickly to set the mission into motion
everyone including sunny and jimmy
starts to evacuate while houseman is
invited to join the mission since he
knows about megastructures more than
them
they all board the shuttle and prepare
to launch
lucky for them they manage to launch and
depart from earth just before a huge
ocean wave caused by gravitational
abnormality hits them however one of the
machines suddenly dies and they start
losing speed
houseman and joe panic but thanks to
harper's skill they eventually manage to
reach outer space in space they refuel
the spaceship before making their way to
the moon which almost collides with the
earth it's also seen that the moon's
debris starts raining down on the earth
meanwhile sunny jimmy and michelle
manage to escape from the water and are
on their way to colorado
not long after doug calls jimmy to
ensure they are safe
unfortunately they are robbed by thieves
and they are forced to walk while
searching for another car
as the moon draws nearer another
gravitational shift occurs causing
people to be pulled up into the air
michelle sunny and jimmy make it to
sunny's relative's place but a lady
appears and starts shooting them because
she thinks they are intruders
tom who is actually brenda's new husband
comes out to pick them up
they gather at tom's house but the
meteor keeps striking and michelle
suggests they immediately head over to
colorado
the trio eventually arrive at the moon
and place the emp at the predetermined
location as bait the swarm then shows up
and surrounds the emp
however just before harper detonates the
emp the swarm notices them and proceeds
to attack the shuttle
they break all the electronic devices
causing the swarm to retreat to the hole
immediately
the crew concludes that the swarm's
programmed to seek out organic matter in
an electronic environment
realizing they have less than two hours
before the military nukes the moon
harper suggests they explore the moon
and get into the hole
the trio make it onto the moon's core
where houseman realizes that his theory
about moon and megastructures is true
they reactivate the shuttle's power and
while exploring the core the swarm
appears again and heads towards them
however the shuttle starts moving on its
own as if something is controlling it
right before the shuttle is destroyed by
the swarm they are pulled into a room
that the swarm is unable to break into
the crash knocks the entire crew
unconscious
back on earth as sunny and the others
are preparing themselves before
departing the thieves from earlier show
up and try to rob them but sunny and tom
hold them off with guns
they go to the car and drive away
not long after the thieves chase after
them and attempt to run them off the
road
suddenly another gravitational shift
occurs which indirectly helps the family
to get away from the thieves
sunny and the others manage to drive off
a ramp to safety while the thieves crash
their cars at the same time the
president of the united states issues an
order to launch nukes to destroy the
moon
sunny and the family then put on oxygen
masks as the air starts to thin and then
make their way to a cave for safety on
the other hand housman and joe awaken
and somehow manage to breathe without
wearing masks
however harper is nowhere to be found
joe finds out that there are two
separate entities on the moon and one of
them is trying to help them
harper wakes up in a room where he meets
the moon's operating system which takes
the form of sunny as a child
the os reveals it was created by ancient
humans billions of years ago when
technologies were so advanced and wars
were only memories of long bygone times
it adds that the swarm is an artificial
intelligence to serve humans at that
time but one day it took on a mind of
its own transforming into countless
swarms of nanotechnology and killing its
creators to eliminate any threat to its
existence
since the swarms attack all electronic
objects that contain organic life their
ancestors gave up their existence so
that humans could be reborn one day
lastly the os tells harper that the only
way to defeat the swarm is to lure it
away from the core so the moon will
automatically return to its orbit
after that the crew regroup again and
eventually find a new shuttle with a
special weapon equipped with in it
they make one last attempt to battle the
swarm
nikki eventually reaches the others but
when sunny and michelle attempt to go
find tom sunny is knocked away by a
falling tree that pins him down
back in the moon the trio try to lower
the swarm out of the moon's core
harper offers to sacrifice himself to
stay behind and eliminates the swarm
while ordering the others to return to
the earth
but as harper and joe argue houseman
silently locks himself with the emp and
releases himself from the shuttle
just after harper and joe bid him
farewell the swarm emerges and surrounds
housman's pod
he then detonates the emp which
successfully kills the swarm while
sending the moon back to its original
position
meanwhile harper and joe escape from the
moon on time and luckily they are close
enough to earth to fly out on a pod
michelle rescues sonny and both of them
managed to reach the bunker the
following day harper and joe survive
from the crash and reunite with their
families
in the moon houseman's consciousness is
uploaded to the moon's base
he is welcomed by the operating system
which takes the form of his mother
the os tells him that they are about to
get started on something big
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching